[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
Marruecos clasificó a cuartos de final
del mundial luego de ganar en los
penaltis a las selección española que
dominó pero sin crear excesivo peligro
Durante los 120 minutos del encuentro
Bono el portero marroquí Héroe Al atajar
2 de los tres penaltis lanzados por
España
apabullante victoria de Portugal frente
a una suiza que ofreció demasiado poco
para estar disputando unos octavos de
final de un mundial Cristiano Ronaldo
comenzó el encuentro desde el banquillo
Ahora les espera Marruecos en cuartos de
final
y el viernes darán comienzo los cuartos
de final precisamente luego de la
jornada de descanso que tendrá lugar el
jueves Argentina y Brasil las dos
selecciones latinoamericanas en liza
abrirán frente a Países Bajos y Croacia
respectivamente
para analizar el desarrollo de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio saso periodista de radio Blue en
Colombia bienvenido a este espacio de
France 24 Hola Rodrigo un gusto
saludarte Cómo te va pues muy bien Vamos
a ver analizando muy bien pese a la
derrota de España vamos a seguir también
analizando toda la información desde
Qatar con nuestra enviada especial allí
a Qatar a doha Natalia Ruiz giraldo que
nos trae todos los detalles de primera
mano de lo que ocurre Precisamente en el
reino catari Saludos Natalia
Hola muy buenas noches Rodrigo enseguida
estaremos contigo pero antes vamos a
hablar de la sorpresa que supuso el
penúltimo partido de estos octavos de
final Marruecos se clasificó por primera
vez en la historia para unos cuartos
mundialistas y lo hizo antes su vecino
del Norte España de quien se esperaba
que el mal rendimiento de la fase de
grupos fuera solo un Espejismo nuestro
enviado especial a Qatar Juan pupiales
nos trae los detalles del encuentro
el primer mundial celebrado en un país
árabe tiene ya a una selección árabe
entre las ocho mejores del torneo
Marruecos se impuso a España en la tanda
de penaltis para por primera vez avanzar
hacia los cuartos de final de una copa
mundo encuentro que terminó a cero
después de 120 minutos y con Los Leones
del Atlas imponiéndose a la roja en la
definición del punto de penalti una
primera parte que tuvimos en este
encuentro con ambos equipos jugando con
las líneas muy adelantadas prácticamente
en un tercio de campo para la segunda
parte Marruecos decidió esperar un poco
más a España que para esos segundos 45
minutos contó ya con la presencia de su
goleador Álvaro morata que no fue
inicialista en el encuentro morata le
dio más aire y más profundidad a la
ofensiva de la roja que aún así siguió
mostrando una gran falta de Gol para la
prórroga Marruecos siguió aguantando y
se llegó a los penales con una ocasión
clarísima un disparo al palo de Pablo
Sarabia Sarabia que fue precisamente
quien falló el primer penalti para los
españoles con España ningún jugador
consiguió marcar desde el punto de
castigo además de Sarabia fallaron
también Carlos Soler Y Sergio busquet
con Marruecos el Héroe fue Bono el
portero del Sevilla con dos atajadas y
también
su lateral quien fue quien marcó ese
tanto que pone a los Leones del Atlas en
la siguiente instancia aquí en las
calles de doha se canta oe oe magrette
Bueno antes de entrar al análisis con
nuestro invitado nos vamos a ir también
hasta Marruecos concretamente a
marrakech desde donde ha estado
siguiendo el partido nuestra
corresponsal Sofía catalá y tras la
victoria las calles del reino marroquí
se han convertido en una auténtica
fiesta recordemos que es el único equipo
africano en liza aún en este mundial
alegría histórica aquí en Marruecos hay
tras la victoria ante la selección
española que otorga a los Leones del
Atlas el paso a cuartos de final es una
victoria que no tiene precedentes aquí
es la primera vez en la historia de
Marruecos que la selección nacional se
clasifica para cuartos de final Y es que
el país magrebí este año tiene la mejor
selección de todos sus tiempos y así lo
ha demostrado en este Duelo contra
España un duelo muy reñido hasta el
último momento en el que Marruecos Ha
logrado imponerse en la fase de penaltis
aquí en marrakech y en todas las
ciudades del estado se prevé una larga
noche de festejos para celebrar como
decimos a esta Victoria histórica que ha
conseguido unir a todo un país como Ven
aquí felicidad absoluta a todo el mundo
está de celebración
hoy hemos ganado ha ganado Marruecos
Bono es un gran hombre
[Aplausos]
Dónde está Dónde está España
estamos muy contentos Es la primera vez
que Marruecos logra pasar siempre
Marruecos viva Marruecos
[Aplausos]
Ahora sí venimos ya hasta este estudio
para analizar este partido con nuestro
invitado Octavio saso Octavio la verdad
que para mí personalmente ha sido una
sorpresa creo que mucha gente pensaba
que quizás ganaría España porque empezó
bien con ese partido contra Costa Rica
con un 7-0 Es verdad que luego en la
fase de grupo su rendimiento no ha sido
el mismo fue quizás un Espejismo aquel
resultado frente a Costa Rica Qué ha
hecho aparte Marruecos para ganar este
partido yo creo Rodrigo que en principio
Más allá de poder digamos decir que lo
de Marruecos fue una sorpresa yo creo
que fue una sorpresa lo mal que jugó
España hoy porque que un equipo de Luis
Enrique que un equipo como el español
con esa capacidad con esa calidad sobre
todo en los jugadores jóvenes que tiene
no sea capaz de pegarle el arco es
realmente llamativo Más allá de luego
las capacidades que tenga Marruecos o no
para complicarte el partido todo termina
cayéndose es por deficiencias de España
más que por virtudes de la selección
marroquí Entonces cuando tienes a un
equipo que en el primer goleó siete cero
porque tenía que hacerlo porque el rival
fue realmente pobre como Costa Rica
luego en el partido contra Alemania
incluso jugaste muy bien dejaste
mostraste muy buenas cosas en ese
partido Más allá del empate el el Duelo
frente a Japón y el de hoy frente a
Marruecos es una caída libre La verdad
es que lo de España es sorprendente
sobre todo por eso por no patear al arco
por no generar ocasiones de gol por más
de que tú tengas la posesión de la
pelota hoy lo demostraste que que por
más de que la tengas si no pateas al
arco no no eres efectivo Entonces eso es
lo que preocupa y complica de un partido
como el de hoy para que España se quede
fuera de la Copa Sí desde luego Octavio
ha sido una de las cosas más criticadas
Desde luego hoy en la prensa española a
esta selección que no han ido a tirar al
arco cuando la defensa de Marruecos
estaba muy poblada y vamos precisamente
con Marruecos que es la protagonista
Cómo crees que tendrá ese cuarto con ese
partido contra Portugal en cuartos les
podremos ver en semifinales yo creo que
evidentemente como son dos rivales
diferentes contra España mar los apostó
desde el inicio prácticamente a mantener
el partido en cero sabiendo que si lo
estiraban iban a cansar y van a agotar
físicamente al seleccionado español y
luego en la tanda de penales Marruecos
evidentemente fue mucho más que que
España que prácticamente ni siquiera se
presentó en los penales por la forma
displicente en que lo cobraron pero me
parece que Portugal es otro rival
totalmente diferente Portugal no le va a
permitir ellas Esa esa digamos esos
detalles que le permitió hoy España al
seleccionado marroquí Portugal va a
tener que Marruecos va a tener que
defender muchísimo mejor frente a
Portugal que es un equipo mucho más
ofensivo que el español que tiene mucha
más Potencia de la mitad de la cancha
hacia arriba y que aprovecha cada uno de
los espacios que le deja los los rivales
hoy trituró a Suiza Portugal viene
marcando una diferencia importante
frente a los rivales y creo que
Marruecos va a tener que tomar otros
recaudos en función del rival de todas
maneras todo Rodrigo de aquí en adelante
ya es muchísima ganancia para el
seleccionado marroquí desde luego ya
haber llegado hasta este punto es algo
muy importante para ellos ya han
demostrado incluso a veces que cuando
quieren saben combinar y tienen calidad
el equipo marroquí vamos precisamente al
segundo partido de esta última jornada
que nos avanzaba Octavio Portugal se
impuso con Clara autoridad al combinado
suizo una Portugal que salió con Ronaldo
en el banquillo y que ya temprano con
gol en el minuto 17 demostró que no
salía especular conectamos con nuestra
enviada especial a Qatar Natalia Ruiz
giraldo quien ha estado viendo
precisamente este partido Natalia Con
qué planteamiento salieron los lusos al
césped
pues salieron finalmente muy ofensivos
salieron con muy buenos contraataques y
finalmente eso fue lo que se vio a lo
largo de todo este partido en el que
aniquilaron a los suizos los suizos que
en realidad no los vimos casi nunca
entre en esos 90 minutos muy distinto el
planteamiento de los suizos hoy al que
habíamos visto en el partido previo
cuando habían ganado ante Serbia acá no
no se vio a Shakira sino unas única vez
cuando tuvo una oportunidad de abrir el
marcador en una jugada de pelota quieta
pero no vimos allá acá simplemente
tuvimos a kanji que fue el único que
logró finalmente descontar ese abultado
marcador ya en ese momento iba cinco
goles a uno y finalmente pues tuvimos a
un Portugal que llegaba muy bien con muy
buenas jugadas colectivas más allá de lo
que vino realizando pues obviamente este
sustituto de Cristiano Ronaldo que marcó
este este triplete Gonzalo Ramos pero
también excelentes jugados colectivas
como les mencionaba quizás el cuarto gol
el de guerreiro que parte de una jugada
de Joao Félix va entonces parte Desde
allí va incluso por por Octavio por
Ramos y termina finalmente en ese gol
Así que Portugal pues se le vio bastante
sólido muy sin sin muchísimos errores en
el primer tiempo ya habían tenido cinco
oportunidades de tiro a la portería y
pues finalmente eso es lo que se refleja
en el resultado que tenemos el día de
hoy un resultado bastante abultado de
seis goles aún pues Natalia Muchas
gracias por este reporte mañana y
jornada de descanso allí en Qatar
también para vosotros que os lo merecéis
por el trabajo hecho hasta ahora vuelvo
contigo Octavio porque estamos viendo
que quizás Portugal es una de las
elecciones que avanza con mayor paso
firme posiblemente junto a Brasil y
Francia qué crees que son las claves de
este paso firme con el que avanza
Portugal las claves de este equipo y hoy
hemos tenido un dato curioso que no ha
salido desde el inicio Cristiano Ronaldo
sabemos algo de por qué esa decisión si
yo yo creo que en principio Rodrigo el
seleccionado portugués hizo hoy el
partido que ellos estaban buscando
durante toda la copa si hablamos de
plantel de calidad de plantel
individualmente todos sabemos que
Portugal es un gran candidato por la
cantidad de jugadores que tiene Incluso
como bien explicas se da el lujo de
sentar a Cristiano Ronaldo ha leado es
decir tiene mucho talento en el banco de
los suplentes inclusive Y eso le permite
a Fernando Santos tener una gama
importante de jugadores con la con la
que puede disponer peringo en ninguno de
los partidos hasta acá había mostrado
contundencia como equipo como colectivo
y hoy dejando aparte incluso que
Cristiano Ronaldo tomó esa decisión
Fernando Santos que seguramente viene
dada por el hecho que que se presentó en
el último Duelo cuando no le no le gustó
el cambio y que luego Fernando Santos
declaraba que no había visto la reacción
y que le había incomodado Esa esa
reacción seguramente viene de ahí pero
más allá de eso Fernando Santos tomó la
decisión incluso dejar en el banco de
los cancelo otro de los referentes de
este equipo y en función de Eso me
parece que Portugal hoy dio un paso
adelante porque le mostró al mundo que
sin esos jugadores todavía el colectivo
funciona Y a partir de eso Portugal ya
en esta serie mata mata mano a mano Es
realmente un equipo muy poderoso yo creo
que Portugal se encamina seguramente acá
con el hecho de no enfrentar a España en
el camino va a tener la posibilidad
frente a Marruecos de jugar una
semifinal de un mundial que es el gran
objetivo de este grupo no y hablando del
colectivo un portugués precisamente José
mourinho criticó al inicio de este
mundial que los jugadores europeos no se
centraban tanto en el equipo como en sus
individualidades pues quizás aquí
tenemos una de esas buenos ejemplos y
hablabas ya de Marruecos lo adelantabas
antes también va a ser un partido muy
diferente al que hemos visto contra
España qué podríamos ver dados los dos
diferentes tipos de fútbol que se ven en
Portugal y en Marruecos yo creo que acá
la diferencia va a estar en que Portugal
no tiene digamos el manejo de pelota que
la selección española es decir la
posesión no va a ser la virtud de
Portugal en el partido Portugal es un
equipo mucho más vertical mucho más de
ataque mucho más concreto esa razón va a
obligar a Marruecos a retroceder y a
tratar de salir cuando Portugal le de
espacios cuando Portugal le genera
alguna posibilidad seguramente acá Más
allá de que el partido de hoy también
fue dominado durante mucho tiempo por
España pero sin trasladar ese dominio al
área rival sin ser contundente en el
área de que defendía abono la diferencia
va a estar en que Portugal sí lo hace
Portugal es un equipo que tiene esa
capacidad de llegar a pisar el área y
rápidamente te liquidas y le das el
espacio entonces Portugal va a tener esa
posibilidad y Marruecos va a tener que
defender mucho mejor de lo que lo hizo
frente a España aprovechando si Portugal
deja algún error para para poder generar
ese contragolpe que ha sido una virtud
de Marruecos a lo largo del mundial Sí
desde luego Yo además viendo el partido
de España esta mañana pronto se vio no
que Marruecos iba a jugar a ese
contragolpe porque probablemente que
España iba a jugar a dominar la pelota
vamos ahora con el resto de partidos ya
de los cuartos de final con todos los
partidos de octavos terminados y en
estos Y es que mañana habrá jornada de
descanso antes de que comiencen los
cuartos el próximo viernes en los que
tendremos los siguientes enfrentamientos
por un lado la selección argentina que
por fin convenció en su último partido
jugará contra Países Bajos jugará el
viernes También Brasil frente al actual
subcampeona Croacia partidazo el sábado
entre Inglaterra y Francia y cerrará los
cuartos este Marruecos frente a Portugal
del que estábamos hablando volvemos con
Octavio veníamos diciendo que Argentina
y Brasil abren la jornada de cuartos de
final una jornada como digo empezará
Argentina contra Países Bajos si no me
confundo ahora y es quizás Países Bajos
una de las tapadas de este mundial hemos
visto que con la llegada de vangar al
banquillo han vuelto a ser una selección
de nuevo competitiva exactamente tú das
una palabra que es importante es
competitiva más no sé si es contundente
la selección de Países Bajos hasta acá
ha tenido rivales que lo han incomodado
poco
ha mostrado evidentemente que tiene
jerarquía porque tiene jugadores de de
mucho talento y experiencia como banda y
como enfis de Payo el propio Frankie de
John Pero le falta enfrentarse a un
rival que lo incomode de verdad como
puede ser el seleccionado argentino y
también Rodrigo para Argentina es la
gran prueba porque evidentemente hasta
acá Más allá de poder enfrentar a un
rival como Polonia no tuvo a un
contrincante de realmente peso como
puede ser Países Bajos va a ser un
partido que además tiene muchísima
historia final de mundial se han
enfrentado recientemente en Brasil 2014
todo lo que implica un enfrentamiento
entre Países Bajos y Argentina y eso va
a generar que sea un un duelo muy
llamativo y vamos a hablar de la otra
selección latinoamericana de Brasil que
también llega con paso firme hasta ahora
quizás está diciendo que no es un juego
tan vistoso no como el que nos tiene
acostumbrado a Brasil no tienen ese yoga
bonito típico de la selección brasileña
pero están llegando bien han ganado con
contundencia y llegaron ya en la segunda
jornada de la fase de grupos a
clasificarse que hemos visto de Brasil
hasta ahora y podríamos decir que es la
gran favorita este torneo o es mucho
decir no es la gran favorita la gran
favorita es un equipo mucho más
pragmático como bien dices No no utiliza
el yodonito como excusa para para lo
demás Aunque la última imagen que nos va
a quedar es ese baile que le pega Corea
del Sur incluyendo el baile de sus
jugadores y de su propio entrenador
evidentemente eso es más cercano a la
realidad de histórica de Brasil ese ese
partido y la forma en cómo lo
resolvieron Brasil está hecho para este
tipo de partidos Brasil está hecho para
ese tipo de circunstancias ellos pueden
jugar muy mal la fase de grupos pero
cuando llegan a esta a esta etapa de
juego terminan soltándose porque saben
que la Copa Mundial Es realmente su
escenario yo creo Rodrigo que que viendo
como que lo hacía les jugó Japón no
tengo la menor duda que Brasil va a
seguir en camino y que si todo se da y
todo se alinea vamos a tener las
semifinal esperada por todo el planeta
que es Brasil y y Argentina seguramente
desde luego una semifinal preciosa
veremos que han pasado de los dos porque
podría ser el último mundial de Leo
Messi por otro lado está otra estrella
Neymar que ha vuelto de su lesión será
un juego desde luego muy bonito Yo creo
que es muy factible que pase esa
semifinal Muchas gracias Octavio por
estar una tarde más aquí con nosotros en
France 24 contrario un gusto bueno
seguimos con los últimos noticias de
este mundial de Qatar empezamos con el
estadio 974 que comenzó a ser
desmantelado luego de albergar su último
encuentro en este mundial el que
enfrentó precisamente a Corea del Sur y
a Brasil recordemos que este estadio fue
construido con contenedores de carga
para ser desmantelado posteriormente
y Argentina volvió a los entrenamientos
luego de clasificar a cuartos de final
tras ganar por dos goles a uno a la
selección de Australia Ángel Di María
lesionado estuvo ausente en el entreno
hasta aquí el Diario del mundial los
invitamos a acompañarnos de nuevo mañana
con nuestro programa diario Mientras
tanto sigan con la programación de
France 24
[Música]